hey we're over here in Las Vegas at CES
and we got something pretty cool here
well something I think is a pretty big
deal something I've wanted for a really
long time it's wireless power believe it
or not we hours for power mass we
wirelessly charge your favorite devices
without the tangled wires that you see
in your home and basically our
technology were using is magnetic
induction right okay and what we're
really doing is we're transferring
energy orthosis power now what's the
distinction between energy to power the
distinction is is that when you transfer
energy you can do things like drive
power to illuminate these LEDs that are
sitting in water you know usually water
electricity you know what out right so
this table right now is lined up with
your technology right this yeah
particular spot at least for now is a
demo yes right yeah what's nice about
our technology is we can embed it at the
table tops into our walls so you could
put these things space them out every
couple of inches you can power a blender
a toaster a microwave your LCD
television in your bedroom you can
basically power anything right so you're
starting out small first you're starting
out with the this device is already on
sale right well it's going to be on sale
in the fourth quarter of the CDR I mean
we're starting with our mat and receiver
systems that are going to be pretty much
at all retail this fall you can use
different voltages to I just have well
we're still plugged in technically
you're still wired but this is one
connection and you can just imagine this
like in a bigger picture thing like
eventually if we line our homes with
this kind of stuff we could just have
wireless everything just like put your
devices on a kitchen table for example
absolutely and what's your efficiency
efficiency ratio our efficiency is
actually tremendous we have some of our
own proprietary technology because
typically magnetic induction people say
slow charging and not efficient our
efficiency is well over ninety percent
we have the highest ratings of energy
status people have been trying to do
stuff like this for years I've always
seen the efficiency something like forty
percent yeah twenty based adapter it
comes with a device
is sixty percent we're well over ninety
percent and what's really important
because everybody in this country wants
to like everything you've done instantly
is this charges in real time that means
that if you plug a blackberry into the
wall with this adapter or you charge
your blackberry here it ends up
happening is that people charged in the
same amount of time that that attractive
one very cool stuff in and right now
you're going to start by selling these
receivers these little receivers like
this is what it looks like absolutely
eventually you think if you could get
people thinking about this stuff like
Apple for instance you could get it
embedded in their laptops just shipped
in them right absolutely Brian we
actually have an example of other areas
of the booth where we have a laptop with
the technology built-in we have a phone
blackberry phone at the technology built
in the technology can be scaled to the
same thickness as a piece of tape so we
don't have to go to device makers and
tell them that they need to make their
device larger to accommodate our system
so we believe that in terms of the
future of where technology is going we
think we have the best technology right
so how much would something like this
cost when you're first starting what you
want to pay yeah it's a match our about
a hundred dollars and the the receivers
are going to cost about thirty dollars
which i think is incredible we want to
get this technology in the hands of
consumers and you know you by a rubber
sleeve or a protective sheet of plastic
in the cost you twenty or thirty dollars
so we're making all of our receivers
affordable we're making our Maps
affordable and we look forward to a very
good selling season
you